[Musik]
pattern Wirtschaft ohne Ende nach grünem
Klüngel im Wirtschaftsministerium jetzt
auch noch filzverdacht bei FDP Minister
und immer mehr Deutsche Denkens
auswandern spannende Themen spannende
Gäste heute Abend bei 8:15 Uhr
Journalist Frank lübberding fordert eine
lückenlose Aufklärung des grünen ökoses
Sitzungen Gräber wundert sich über die
Ruhe im Volk bei der Politik würden die
Franzosen schon länger laufen
Kinderschützer und mobbing-experte
Carsten Stahl Wahnsinn gegen Hormon als
pubertäter und Altenpflegerin Isabel
vodic hat nur noch ein Ziel Weg aus
Deutschland das Deutschland hat große
Probleme hat wird auch mit Blick auf die
Ministerin sehr klar der Klingel
Verdacht im Wirtschaftsministerium ist
schon fatal und jetzt gibt es auch noch
filzverdacht bei FDP-Minister Volker
Wissing der Bundesverkehrsminister hat
fleißig neue Leute ins Ministerium
geholt auf top Posten gehoben darunter
auch alte FDP vertraute brisant
insgesamt wurden 18 Stellen sogar ohne
jegliche Ausschreibung vergeben dabei
sind diese im Bundesbeamtengesetz
grundsätzlich vorgeschrieben fünf der
Top-Jobs sind gar abteilungsleiterposten
das Grundgehalt beträgt über 12.000 Euro
im Monat das ergab eine Anfrage der
Unionsfraktion ich finde das fatal
selbstverständlich dürfen auch Minister
mit Menschen arbeiten den sie vertrauen
die sie kennen das können wir alle im
Berufsleben die vielleicht auch in
derselben Partei sind aber
toppersonalien dürfen nicht und zwar
niemals ohne dem Beamtengesetz
vorgesehen Ausschreibung einfach so
verteilt werden wie so kleine Geschenke
Präsente mal eben zu Weihnachten oder
Ostern wird zum Posten dementsprechend
meine erste Frage an Herr Gräber sind
die Ministerien teilweise zu
selbstbedienungsfabrik mutiert in
Deutschland
na gut man muss sich glaube ich im jeden
Fall anschauen ob die Leute jenseits
ihres parteibuchs auch die nötige
fachliche Qualifikation dafür haben das
kann ja durchaus sein dass die FDP auch
so viele fähige top Leute hatten
das stimmt natürlich man darf ja mit
Leuten zusammenarbeiten wenn man weiß
derjenige ist gut mit dem Herr Gräber
habe ich schon ganz lange
zusammengearbeitet ich will weiter mit
ihm arbeiten selbstverständlich denken
an mich wenn sie dann mal Minister sein
sollte
bleibt kein Journalisten aber der Punkt
ist doch da warum ohne Ausschreibung
weil wenn ich doch schon wüsste ja der
Gräber der ist richtig gut top Mann bei
mir Ministerium da mache ich mit dem
doch erst recht eine Ausschreibung ja
warum nicht ja
also man muss es sich auf jeden Fall
anschauen im Detail und ich glaube
Misstrauen ist da immer angebracht also
dass die Öffentlichkeit oder die
politische Konkurrenz da auch den Finger
drauf legt und hinschaut ist vollkommen
richtig weil die Gefahr dass es da auch
um persönliche gefährlichkeiten
Gesellschaft geht ist immer da
nur muss man sich auch anschauen so ein
Ministerium natürlich wird das wurde das
schon immer auch nach Parteibuch besetzt
solche Positionen das liegt glaube ich
auch in der Funktionsweise unserer
Demokratie und umso wichtiger ist auch
der Wechsel dass eben nicht nur eine
Partei ein Ministerium über Jahrzehnte
wie den erdhof behandelt sondern dass es
eben immer auch mal wieder zu wechseln
kommt und dadurch auch manche sind
Bewegung kommt Menschen ihre Ruhe und
Ausgewogenheit werden wir heute noch bei
8:15 Uhr brauchen denn es ist ja auch
Carsten Stahl in der Runde und ob der
jetzt auch mit so viel ja fast
Verständnis über das FDP Ministerium von
Volker ein bisschen spricht da bin ich
jetzt mal gespannt also ich habe für
vieles Verständnis aber nicht mehr für
diese Politik und diese Regierung die
ein Höchstmaß Anforderungen an die
Bürger stellt aber selbst nicht bereit
ist auch nur eine einzige davon zu
erfüllen und ich persönlich
verlange von Vorbildern dass sie es
vormachen und sich vorbildlich verhalten
und diese ganze Mentalität die da
abläuft sich die Pöstchen rausschieben
und wieder ein bisschen Geld hier
zuschieben dazu schieben und wird in
seiner solchen Situationen so einer
Krise wo wir alle auf höchstem finde ich
einfach unverschämt und tragbar und ich
persönlich und du sagst mal klar Deutsch
da muss man einer kräftig durchfegen und
den Mister mal raus fegen dass der
endlich mal Klarheit drin kommt das was
da läuft hat für mich stinkt für mich
nach vielen Dingen aber das Wort
Korruption oder Vetternwirtschaft oder
klaren Strukturen was er da schon
teilweise immer wieder gehört wird ja
sollte man mal hingucken man guckt ja
auch bei anderen Sachen immer genau hin
da will ich dann schon mal jemand
hinschicken aber bitte einen
unabhängigen unabhängigen Gutachter und
nicht wieder einen der irgendwie Partei
zugehörig ist
in welchem Team sind sie Team Gräber
oder teamstahl
ja ich sehe das das Grundproblem
bekommen wir ja gleich noch drauf bei
meinem Thema ist ja gar nicht dass zum
Beispiel natürlich ab bis
Abteilungsleiter Ebene in einem
Ministerium da gibt es ein gewisses
Vertrauensverhältnis das Wort gab es
auch schon früher das Leute dann
dementsprechend ausgetauscht werden bei
beamteten Staatssekretärin war da
sowieso immer schon die konnte man ohne
Angabe von Grün entlassen aber nur weil
es immer schon so war ist das gut weil
dass diese Jobs werden ja von vom
Steuerzahlern
du hast natürlich in einem Ministerium
musst du du bist ja als ministerlichen
Fachmann für alles und als Minister
brauchst du natürlich schon Leute das
ist ja erleben war ja richtig schön
jetzt gerade beim reichen
Familienministerium
er muss natürlich seine Politik
durchsetzen können dafür braucht er eine
gewisse Form von Verlässlichkeit auch
Vertrauen in die entsprechenden Menschen
äh wo ist ein Problem glaube ich ist
wenn bis auf der Referats Ebene also
dort wird ja eigentlich das ein
Fachbeamter tatsächlich also das sind
Leute die die eingestellt werden sich
ein in einem Thema einarbeiten und das
jetzt jahrelang oder sonst wie ich weiß
nicht zehn Jahre lang oder so betreuen
eine Fachkompetenz aufbauen und die
eigentlich ja kein politischen Job haben
sondern sie beschreiben einfach nur eine
gewisse Wirklichkeit ließen das sind
Gesetzentwürfe geben das den
Abteilungsleitern die geben das den
Staatssekretären zur zur Prüfung vor und
dann wird das vielleicht irgendwann
eingesetzt aber das sind wirklich
fachbeamte das klingt ein bisschen so
wie Klüngelei bis zu einem gewissen
Level nee das ist erlaubt und ab dann
nicht mehr nein man muss ja vielleicht
mal Vergleich ziehen mit Amerika in
Amerika haben den ganz anderes System
Amerika fliegen alle raus nach der Wahl
wenn Sie der falschen Partei angehören
und dann kommt komplett neue Leute diese
komplett neuen Leute sind natürlich alle
unabhängig oder so sondern die kommen
Washington gigantisches
Lobbyisten so unfa immer so will also da
muss man sich wirklich auskennen hatte
Bandagen haben und da werden die
entsprechenden Leute in alle Ministerien
hineingesetzt die in irgendeiner Form
dort auch politische Interessen haben
und dieser Partei
nahe stehen bei Trump hat das die ganze
funktioniert ich glaube da hat der hat
bis zum Ende seiner Amtszeit dass ich so
richtig hingekriegt ein funktionsfähigen
Apparat zu bekommen der eigentlich nach
seinen Vertrauen hatte das ist die
Alternative zu diesem System und die das
andere Extrem ist Großbritannien die
hatten schon immer im Berufsbeamtentum
und da gab es in Amerika in England
immer die wunderbare Satire darüber dass
sich der Minister regiert sondern die
Beamten schafft in Wirklichkeit
müssen sie mal ein bisschen googeln da
finden sie denn die schönsten Sachen
dazu
einmal ab wie sehen Sie das denn also
ich würde sagen knapp 150.000 Euro
Jahresgehalt ohne Ausschreibung 18
Stellen in welchem Team am Tisch sind
sie denn also es geht schon eine Allianz
zwischen zwei Team Stahl ist noch
alleine sie können auswählen in welchem
Team sie hier sind also ich muss ehrlich
sagen ich werde auf jeden Fall bei Team
Stahl weil ich finde auch damit viel zu
wenig gemacht und wir brauchen auf jeden
Fall eine unabhängige Seite und nicht
irgendwie andere die schon irgendwie
einer Partei gehörig sind auch vor allem
auf die Ausschreibung bestehen und sagen
da muss mehr gemacht werden auf jeden
Fall Fragen
150.000 Jahresgehalt 18 posten die mal
eben ohne Ausschreibung vergeben werden
wie viel verdient eine Altenpflegerin
ja also wir können davon nur träumen
also wir verdienen wahrscheinlich so
[Musik]
zwei bis bis drei brutto ungefähr und
36.000 pro Monat genau ungefähr ja das
heißt für einen von diesen Posten
könnten wir uns vier Altenpfleger in dem
Land leisten hat formuliert und sie
müssen ja auch ein Bewerbungsverfahren
machen als Altenpflegerin oder der ruft
ja keine Ahnung und da komm mal her
sondern bestellt man sich auch
wahrscheinlich vor und hat verschiedene
vielleicht sogar Probearbeiten habe ich
sogar schon mal gehört gibt's teilweise
ja dementsprechend verstehe ich das
schon auch ihren Unmut definitiv also
das ist ja eh ziemlich schwierig auch
gerade die Branche und sowas muss man ja
auch noch Bedenken ihr fliegt die die
dieses Land aufgebaut haben die die ich
mit Füßen getreten werden die
weggeschlossen weggesperrt werden die
nur noch zum ja dahinvegetieren
zurückgelassen werden wenn es nach der
Politik gehen würde streng genommen
sollte eigentlich jeder spätestens mit
70 in die Kiste hüpfen ja und dafür für
den Job macht ich meine man hat ja immer
so viel in der Pandemie gehört wie sehr
ihr gelobt worden seid und viele viele
Flieger aber angekommen ist von dem Lob
finanziell nichts oder und da sehen wir
doch genau diese Heuchlerei und diese
Politik die sich 12 Millionen plus
einsteckt und uns Bürgern sagt macht den
Gürtel enger also ich persönlich kann
immer nur wieder sagen der Cook geht so
lange bis zum Brunnen bis er bricht und
auch wir können uns Warnwesten anziehen
und Frankreich mal nachahmen vielleicht
gefällt es Dir besser aber wir sind ja
mehr damit beschäftigt klimakleber und
über Klima zu unterhalten zu Frankreich
kommen wir später noch ich fand den
einen Schwenk von Herr Stahl aber ganz
spannend ähm was ist denn da eigentlich
wirklich angekommen in der Pflege weil
der stimmt ja es war die letzten Jahre
zumindest in der Presse glücklicherweise
viele Artikel viel Augenmerk drauf wie
geht's der Pflege heute in Pflegeberufen
im Land also ich merke es passiert was
es tut sich was wir kriegen es auf jeden
Fall mit und ich werde mich auch sehr
gerne für diesen Dank für den Lob auch
und für
das was wir an Dankbarkeit erhalten
haben in dieser schwierigen Zeit mich
bedanken auch für alle Krankenschwestern
und ähm aber ich finde da geht noch mehr
also der geht auf jeden Fall noch viel
mehr und dann muss auf jeden Fall noch
viel viel genug
ja vielleicht können wir ein bisschen
vom Wirtschaftsministerium wegnehmen
Geld und in die Pflege das jetzt
natürlich ein etwas populistischer
Ansatz von mir aber wir kommen
willkommen zu ihrer These ja also die
Energiewende ist ein Milliardengeschäft
wie in jeder Branche gibt es
Lobbyinteressen wie man diese durchsetzt
erleben wir gerade im
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium Robert
habecks Staatssekretär was kann Patrick
reichen ist zum Symbol geworden wie das
Zusammenspiel von Politik Unternehmen
nicht Regierungsorganisation
Wissenschaft und Medien in der Praxis
funktioniert ich nenne das ein
politisches ökonomischen Komplex zur
Energiewende
die wie funktioniert das die Politik
bestellt ein Gutachten das Ergebnis
unterstützt die Politik der staatlichen
Auftraggeber die
Nichtregierungsorganisation machen eine
Kampagne zu deren Gunsten und am Ende
berichten die Medien darüber und auf
allen Ebenen entsteht so ein enormer
politischer Druck man hat ja dann das
Gefühl es gibt Monopol in der
Meinungsbildung und dieser politische
ökonomische Komplex funktioniert halt
wie ein geschlossenes System also da ist
Widerspruch eigentlich nicht mehr
vorgesehen und jemand der widerspricht
sie hat neulich Hans von Storch ja in
der Sendung und Klimaforscher der wird
ja schon sehr schnell in die Ecke des
Klima leugners gestellt oder so etwas
und so funktioniert das Ganze und es
geht also und das zusammenzufassen nicht
nur um ihre politische Ziele Klimawandel
Rettung der Menschheit oder sonst etwas
sondern um die ökonomischen Interessen
aller beteiligten Unternehmen aus der
Branche der inneren Energien brauchen
Aufträge Wissenschaftler finanzieren
ihren Lebensunterhalt mit Studien NGOs
Leben von staatlichen förderaufträgen
und der Großzügigkeit privater Spender
diese betrachten das sogar noch als ein
weltweites Projekt und so ist ein fast
undurchschaubares Dickicht aus Stiftung
Wissenschaften Wissenschaften nicht
Regierungsorganisationen Medienkampagnen
entstanden die der Politik eines
suggeriert es wäre alles alternativlos
in der Energie und klimapolisieren es
ist nicht alternativlos natürlich nicht
das ist natürlich völliger Bullshit und
aber dieses System kommt jetzt gerade
ins Rutschen und dann wollen wir jetzt
auch den Unterschied mal machen zum
ehemaligen csu-ministerium
Bundesverkehrsministerium die hatten das
war ja 20 Jahren er beruft der CSU
was wir jetzt im
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium erleben ist
eine gewisse Form von 30°. also er
besetzt zum Beispiel bis auf die
referatsebene mit Leuten die aus diesem
ganzen Netzwerk herauskommen die
Deutschen immer aktiv waren entweder
schon mal zuvor in dieser Dreistigkeit
ja das ist eine gute Frage die hat mir
auch schon gestellt das ist wie immer
mit historischen Forschung müsste man
untersuchen aber mir ist das in der Form
so nicht eine Milch und ich dass er 45
Jahren mit den Ausschreibungen noch
nicht so Alarm geschlagen haben haben
sie hier aber jetzt schon Wut ja weil
der unter es gibt ja einen Unterschied
da gibt es einen Wissing ein Minister
die besitzt dann irgendwelche Posten
blöd zu sagen mit alten Kumpels wir
hatten auch mal ein Gesundheitsminister
Bar hieß der der hat sogar
Gesetzentwürfe von der privaten
Versicherungswirtschaft schreiben lassen
also das war damals wirklich ein
richtiges Skandal schon Ewigkeit ja
natürlich und aber das ist halt äh da
fehlt halt die wissenschaftliche
Unterstützung im
Bundesverkehrsministerium da fehlen die
nicht Regierungsorganisation ich kenne
niemand der sich für die FDP
Verkehrsexperten im Ministerium auf die
Straße klebt da gibt's keine Medien die
positiv berichten und
genau und das heißt dieses Netzwerk ist
natürlich gar nicht und das ist ein
riesiges grünes Netzwerk und das hat
sich über die letzten 20 25 Jahre ein
richtiges Netzwerk das wenn man sich so
unsere Freunde Bekannte so Schaubilder
zugestellt die werden in Zukunft
kommenden Tagen wahrscheinlich auch in
anderen Medien erscheinen kann jetzt
nicht sagen genau und diese und wenn man
sich die anguckt dann merkt man wie
personelle Verknüpfung existieren das
ist der Fall reichen ist ja sehr schon
fast Satire ne und das dann ausgerechnet
noch der FD frühere FDP
Landesvorsitzender Niedersachsen ein
Schwager von Herrn reichen selbst es ist
natürlich sehr schon fast eine real
sortiere also wenn wir doch satirik
hätten die können sich darüber natürlich
die personellen familiären oder
freundschaftlichen Beziehungen die sind
natürlich ein Problem aber die sind
glaube ich nicht der Kern des Problems
der Kern ist dass die alle wirklich aus
einer Denkrichtung kommen die noch dazu
eigentlich fast so ein bisschen
irrsinnig ist nämlich die Idee dass
Deutschland auf seinem Staatsgebiet sich
irgendwie Energie unabhängig von Wind
und Sonne was machen kann also Energie
unabhängig ist kein Ideologie wenn wir
mit auf eigenem staatsgebieten mit Wind
und Sonne arbeiten das wird nie und
immer passieren das ist eigentlich fast
schon eine Vorstellung also dass man
damit in Deutschland Wahlen gewinnen
kann
zeigt eigentlich schon das Jahr
Arbeitsplätze entstehen und diese
Transformation mit dem Tun
Wahrheit auch sein dass die Grünen
eigentlich genau diese schrumpfen wollen
weil schrumpfen ist ja eigentlich gut
für den Klimawandel gegen den Klima und
dementsprechend wollen die auch uns
Grünen schrumpfen die die Ideologie der
Energiewende in Deutschland ist ja
eigentlich eine Geburt der Anti
atombewegung das heißt es ging damals ja
gar nicht so sehr um den Klimawandel
aufzuhalten sondern es ging immer darum
die Atomkraft zu ersetzen durch durch
Wind und Sonne das Ergebnis sehen wir
jetzt wir schalten jetzt Cola an die
Grünen haben keine Probleme mit
Kohlekraftwerken solange sie nicht am
Atomausstieg äh rütteln müssen
und daher kommt diese Ideologie und sie
war immer von Anfang an verknüpft auch
mit dem wir haben über unsere
Verhältnisse gelebt wir haben zu viele
Energie verbraucht wir müssen Energie
sparen Energie sparen war immer ein Teil
dieser Ideologie nur das Energiesparen
man in der Altbauwohnung in Berlin Mitte
oder im Prenzlauer einfach schön sich
vorstellen kann wobei weiß auch nicht
die Gasetagenheizung dort sind auch
nicht die die tollsten aber es gibt eben
auch auch Leute die sind auf der Autor
angewiesen in der Altenpflegerin die die
nachts zur Schicht fahren muss die
möchte ich in Berlin nicht in die U-Bahn
setzen müssen wie soll sich ihr kleines
Auto schon auch bitte noch künftig
leisten können und soll auch ein
Parkplatz dafür haben können und das
sind alles so Sachen die einfach mit der
Realität dieser Gesellschaft einfach
nicht nicht zueinander passen und das
bricht jetzt so langsam heraus und ich
glaube das wird auch zum
Stimmungsumschwung in Deutschland führen
ja die Grünen sind ja schon gefallen
reichen kommen auch wenn der nur ein
kleiner Fall ist er lieber den kleiner
Fall würde ich sagen
erklärt haben erscheint er doch als ein
kleiner Fall geworden genau also
er kann überall die richtigen Leute
reinsetzen und auch mit guten mit guten
Mitteln ausstatten über fördern
in dem Fall Klüngelei Robert Habeck
Herrn reichen absegen wird herrg reichen
das Bauernopfer doch noch werden oder
wie es da ihre Vermutung in den nächsten
Tagen ja das ist eine ganz spannende
Frage weil es gibt ja wir hatten im
letzten Jahr über Karl Lauterbach
gesprochen und da gilt natürlich jeder
genau dasselbe also ein Minister muss
nur zurücktreten oder muss Maßnahmen
ergreifen wenn er komplett den Rückhalt
in der eigenen Partei verliert wann
verliert er den Rückhalt in der Partei
wenn relevante Teile dieser Partei der
Eindruck haben dass der zu einer
Belastung wird weil das bedeutet
natürlich man das Verlust Parteien aber
weniger Geld das ist ja ganz normal wir
handeln ja nicht anders als andere Leute
in ihrem Berufen also wenn keine Ahnung
wenn wir schon wissen steigen sinken
aufladen oder sonst etwas haben bricht
uns natürlich auch Paniker genauso und
ähm aber das ob das jetzt so passiert
ist halt die Frage weil natürlich haben
diese grünen Kern gelöst glaube ich
mittlerweile auch verstanden
dass das was die Grünen seit 10 15 20
Jahren
erzählen jetzt wo es umsetzen müssen gar
nicht funktioniert nicht und das ist
genau der Punkt und sie und die Grünen
und das ist glaube ich ihr absoluter
Denkfehler sind völlig Kompromiss und
fähig geworden es gab ja überhaupt kein
Grund so jetzt radikal so eine
wärmewende zu machen man kann im
Koalitionsverträgen alles mögliche
hineinschreiben und am Ende handelt man
da irgendwelche Gesetze aus man muss
Rücksicht nehmen auf berechtigte
wirtschaftliche Interessen auch auf
Lobbygruppen wie sehen dass die
Verbraucher was bedeutet das in der
Praxis ist ergibt sich alles aus dem
Gesetzgebungsverfahren und dann kommt
halt manchmal so eine Maus raus also am
Ende von so einem Gesetz sie hatten
gerade einen ganz spannenden Punkt mit
dem Rückhalt in der Partei Herr Stein
müsst nicht auch Minister Rückhalt in
der Bevölkerung haben ich denke mal das
ist das Wichtigste das Problem in der
Politik ist zuerst die Partei dann die
Partei dann die einzelnen und irgendwann
mal der Bürger und ich kann mich daran
erinnern unterbricht mich hier jemand
wenn ich falsch da steht etwas ganz groß
am Bundestag das steht dem deutschen
Volker auf diesen wurde auch ein alt
geschworen aber das deutsche Volk wird
hier gar nicht gefragt die Bürger werden
die nicht gefragt sondern wenn sie
nämlich gefragt worden wären haben über
60% gesagt nein wir lassen die AKWs an
solange bis wir wirklich ein Alternative
haben sie haben entschieden sie
abzuschalten unabhängig davon was sie
noch so getrieben haben ich habe so ein
bisschen das Gefühl es ist wieso die
Grünen wissen es singt jetzt langsam das
beliebtheitsbarometer und zwar rapide
und als wenn wir drücken jetzt mal
schnell alles durch damit wir alles
geschafft haben bloß alles schnell weg
damit es nicht mehr Aufbau aber es ist
so als wenn ich alles kaputt mache
hinterher kann kein neuer neu machen und
ich weiß nicht ob das wirklich im Sinne
der Bürger ist weil die Bürger sollten
eigentlich ein Mitbestimmungsrecht haben
für die diese gewählt haben und wenn die
diese gewählt haben nicht im Sinne der
Bürger handeln dann missbrauchen sie Amt
und macht in dem falschen Händen war
schon immer gefährlich und eine
Ideologie die man vorantreibt die kann
nie das richtige Mittel sein es gibt
immer Kompromiss wir müssen was fürs tun
aber das hier abgezogen
bisschen politisches Interesse und
mittlerweile eine Besessenheit und bis
zum Beschuss in meinen Augen bis zu
Vetternwirtschaft wo der eine der
anderen noch stützt und macht eine tut
und da bin ich übrigens hier ganz klares
Team was die Grünen betrifft aber da
sind wir uns wahrscheinlich viele einig
aber wir werden irgendwie nicht gehört
die machen munter weiter die können
Bescheid wissen lügen betrügen mit
Titeln nicht genau nehmen aber sie
bleiben weiter am Abend gute Ideologie
haben Sie auch schon im Wahlkampf
gezeigt und sie wurden ja auch gewählt
überlegen also der demokratisch gewählt
die Grünen aber doch was anderes hatte
jetzt wirklich mal wieder sprechen also
wir sind ja fünf fünf Meinungen hier ich
kenne hunderte Bürger und hunderte
Bürger haben völlig unterschiedliche
Meinung zu einem alle möglichen Themen
wer ist das überhaupt der Bürger der
Bürger als äh als als Masse als Box
populi der da irgendwann mal in
irgendwelche mooskopischen und Umfragen
zu irgendwelchen Themen befragt oder das
dann angeblich der Bürger also ich kenne
nur Bürger mit sehr unterschiedlichen
Meinung sehr unterschiedlichen
Lebensläufen sie haben ganz anderen
Lebens Hintergrund wahrscheinlich als
ich oder sie oder sie und wir alle und
das ist wirklich
nicht zu reden aber der der
entscheidende Punkt ist sie haben
natürlich macht also wenn die Grünen und
das habe ich ja eben zum Ausdruck
gebracht wenn die Grünen erleben dass
sie
drohen Wanja lang und die haben ja beim
Sinne bei Bundestagswahl vor der
Bundestagswahl gestartet mit über 20%
Kanzlerin gesehen ja genau 15 und wenn
die jetzt wirklich merken oder so dass
sie Unterstützung nachlässt also diese
seit 2015 man muss ja wissen wo die
Grünen her kam die kamen 2013 aus der
Bundestagswahl mit 8 % die werden immer
die kleinste Partei und seit 2015 haben
die kontinuierlichen Aufschwung gemacht
die haben Sie das geschafft Greta
tunberg sei Dank nee das nicht sondern
die Grünen haben sich inszeniert in
diesem Parteiensystem ich meine wir
hatten ja alle die Schnauze voll von der
großen Koalition die Schiene ewig zu
dauern und Angela Merkel konnten auch
nicht mehr sehen und ähm wir ganz
unterschiedliche Meinungen ja aber es
sehr viele das gab einfach so eine
gewisse so ein Missmut uns mal so
auszudrücken das drückt er sich
natürlich in der flüchtlingskrise kann
war das ja richtige Shepherd und die
Grünen haben das damals sehr geschickt
gemacht sie haben sich eigentlich so als
die gute Alternative Hoffnungsträger zu
der groko inszeniert und gleichzeitig
als die radikale Alternative zur AFD die
waren die waren Gegner der AFD und so
haben die ihren Wiederaufstieg geschafft
ja und auch entschuldigt aber ich glaube
ganz maßgeblich für den
zwischenzeitlichen Erfolg der Grünen der
jetzt eben schon wieder im Sinne ist und
ich glaube auch noch weiter sinken wird
war ja dieses Image was was habe ich
auch am Anfang ja verkörpert hat dieses
eben dieses pragmatischen ja ich bin für
Klimaschutz und ja ich bin grüner aber
ich bin eben kein
Jürgen Trittin um das Gegenbeispiel zu
nehmen wobei der zu seiner
Regierungszeit auch Kompromisse gemacht
hat aber der eben sehr thematisch
dogmatisch unterwegs ist und jetzt
stellt sich aber raus habe ich ist die
Fassade habe ich ist der der mit der
knaut diesem Gesicht irgendwie manchmal
ganz sympathisch in die Kameras wird
eine zittrige Stimme ja der hat aber
Habig ist nicht der der entscheidet was
bei den Grünen läuft das sind die sind
in sich sehr zerstritten und bei den
Grünen sind wirklich Leute am Werk die
im Grunde ich weiß nicht ob sie die
Industrie zerstören wollen aber die im
Grunde kein Problem damit haben
immer noch die gibt es immer noch zwei
Flügeln sie würden nicht sagen dass es
langsam schon fast eins das ist eine
geschickte PR-Geschichte gewesen am
Anfang oder in dieser Wahlkampfphase das
andere Lena bärburg die ich jetzt dem
linken Flügel zu rechnen würde und habe
der dem real,- Flügel eindeutig
zuzurechnen ist dass die so dieses
harmonische Bild diese tollen Fotos wo
sie da irgendwie im in der Abend sondern
über das Kopfsteinpflaster stolziert
sind das war alles Show das war gespielt
die beiden sind verfeindet Werbung
kämpft intern massiv gegen habe ich und
wenn dieser Staatssekretär reichen jetzt
stürzen wird
innerhalb der Parteien ja dann standen
die beiden ja schon besser zusammen
haarig und bärbock als dann während des
Wahlkampfes oder
da bin ich zu wenig drin aber was ich so
höre jetzt ja jetzt ist dass die
verfeindet sind dass es wohl klar naja
aber nicht friedlich aus wäre von beiden
dann habe Kette wäre gerne kannst Du
Kandidat geworden das war auch ein
Machtkampf
ja ich glaube zum Beispiel dass diese
These von realophonie aus der
Anfangsseite grün spielt heute überhaupt
keine Rolle die meisten Grünen die heute
sind sind Pragmatiker die wollen Politik
machen und das hauptberuflich aber wo
sind die Pragmatiker die Pragmatiker das
Problem ist dass der jemand der der
Patrick reichen der ist ja äh in seine
ganzen Vita hatte er gelernt als
wissenschaftlich gearbeitet war war
schon bei Trittin im Umweltministerium
ist dann die verschiedensten Stufen
entlang gegangen das machst du nur das
machst du nicht wenn du jetzt so ein
Fundy bist wie Frau Dietfurt sie liegen
Angedenken also die damals bei den
Grünen große Rolle spielte das spielt
alles gar keine Rolle mehr sondern was
der was bei den bei den Typus reichen
jetzt einfach den auf die Füße fällt ist
dass die schlicht und einfach
undurchdachte Konzeptionen haben und im
Grunde sind sie an die Regierung
gekommen die haben ja bis
21 bis zur Wahl haben die Grünen 60
Jahre immer erzählt ja die Energiewende
klappt ja deswegen nicht weil da sitzen
im Bundeswirtschaftsministerium lauter
Leute die das systematisch boykottiert
ne gab es eine tolle Diskussion über
Mindestabstand Windräder Häuser zu
Siedlung und so etwas und dann die
Grünen immer gesagt wenn wir das erstmal
machen klappt das alles viel besser und
jetzt sehen wir es gab gar nichts aber
das sind alles Pragmatiker durch die
Bahn durch die Pragmatiker haben halt
praktisch funktionieren das ist ein
wirklich eine radikale Idee eines
kompletten Umbaus unseres unserer
Industriegesellschaft in kürzester Zeit
mit verheerenden Wirkungen die auch im
Wirtschaftsministerium niemand wirklich
durchschauen kann und sie machen es
trotzdem und das finde ich nicht
pragmatisch deswegen
Konsequenzen ihrer Konzeptionen sind
diese seit 20 Jahren weiter mit dem Kopf
durch die Wand ja das ist ja die Aufgabe
das ist ja die Aufgabe von Medien das
ist die Aufgabe der Oppositionsparteien
das deutlich zu machen und dann
dementsprechend die deutlich zu machen
wo liegen die Defizite ich meine also
Oppositionspolitiker Friedrich Merz und
sonst was ähm ich meine den wird der 11
der bekommt einen Ball auf Elfmeter
Punkt und der Torwart ist in die Kabine
gegangen er muss ja nur noch
reinschießen in anderen Ländern kann man
auf jeden Fall sagen ja wenn die
Menschen schon auf die Straße gehen da
denkt man nur an Frankreich die machen
ja in Unmut immer sehr laut und sehr
offensiv und Herr Gräber hat dazu heute
auch eine These mitgebracht genau sie
haben vielleicht gerade schon im Verlauf
der Sendung gemerkt dass ich mich ähm
mir große Sorgen mache was in unserem
Land gerade passiert und nicht erlebt
aus persönlichen Gesprächen im bekannten
Kollegen Kreis dass ich bei weitem nicht
der einzige bin die radikale
transformationspolitik ich würde auch
sagen Abbau und Rückbau Politik in
unserem Land die da gerade maßgeblich
von grün aber eben auch den anderen
klein geduldet vonstatten geht
erschreckt mich immer mehr und ich frage
mich in anderen Ländern und ich bekomme
aus der Nähe von Frankreich aus
Baden-Württemberg wir hatten Frankreich
vor der Haustür in so einem Land wie
Frankreich werden die Bürger glaube ich
schon längst auf der Straße wenn wenn es
solche radikalen Pläne die
offensichtlich zu Lasten auch der
einfachen Leute und unsere
Wirtschaftsstandorts gehen umgesetzt
werden sollen und ich frage mich die
Deutschen sind
sehr geduldig aber irgendwann muss die
Stimmung denke ich auch mal kippen und
ich glaube da bin ich bei ihnen schon
Herr Stahl diese Inschrift auf dem
Reichstag dem deutschen Volker an diese
Inschrift muss man einige dieser Leute
tatsächlich lautstarker erinnern glaube
ich in Deutschland Grenze aufgewachsen
was unterscheide sind die Deutschen von
den Franzosen
na die Franzosen die waren ja schon
immer schnell dabei
Französische Revolution kennt man ja aus
den Geschichtsbüchern wenn sie mit ihren
Herrschern nicht zufrieden waren dass
dann kurzer Prozesse gemacht wurde das
in dieser radikalen Form er will ich das
überhaupt gar nicht also bitte nicht
falsch verstehen
gar nicht wieder gut heißen noch fordern
da kommen dann nämlich auch nicht immer
die richtigen danach an die Macht also
die Französische Revolution mit dir
wollen wir nicht in Deutschland arbeiten
das was wir hier als als mega Streik
verkaufen das gilt bei denen als
Mittagspausen aber sie wollen wir wollen
aber jetzt doch nicht noch mehr Streiks
in Deutschland haben oder vielleicht
auch aber vielleicht sollte man mal die
richtigen dreieckigen bisher streiten
oder öffentliche Dienst wer sollte den
streiten
also nicht die metallische Musik
auch sehr wundern na ja
genau vielleicht auch mal in der
Energieindustrie die ja bei der die die
Opfer ist davon ich meine ich frage mal
warum haben wir Deutschland anscheinend
so wenig Feuer in uns wenn man
plattformulierte
[Gelächter]
oder wir beantworten oder wir
beantworten erstmal die Frage ob
vielleicht Herr Stahl ein französisches
Herz in sich hat und kein Deutsch ist
kann nicht sein also vielleicht liegt es
ein bisschen an meinen ganz späten
ungarischen Wurzeln dass ich einfach ein
hohes Geld
ungerechtigkeitsgefühl habe wenn man die
Menschen die Menschen vor allen Dingen
Bürger die Menschen irgendwie im Stich
lässt und vergisst und dann habe ich
hier bin ich jemand der sagt wenn ich es
selber vormache kann ich es auch von
anderen verlangen oder zumindestens
erwarten aber wenn ich es selber nicht
vor mache dann habe ich gar nicht
richtig den Mund aufzumachen oder meiner
Sprache nicht Maul weil entscheidend ist
und tun sie nicht sie sagen dass sie
sagen sie predigen Wasser und saufen
Champagner ja und alle sollten die
machen nur mehr und ich bin da wirklich
bei Ihnen wie lange geht denn der Krug
noch zum Brunnen bis er bricht die
Franzosen werden schon lange draußen ich
persönlich glaube bloß vielleicht geht
es so lange bis es dann wirklich zu ganz
schlimm Dingen kommt und die sollten wir
eigentlich verhindern weil
die Arbeit ich sehe das genauso wenn das
so weitergeht gehen die großen Betriebe
einfach weil es lukrativer ist weg damit
schaffen wir Arbeitsplätze nur nicht bei
uns und wir bleiben dann zurück und
wendet ein paar radikalen Menschen die
eine Ideologie vertreten wollen dass wir
eine Postkutschen rumrennen und
Brunnenwasser trinke das hat eine schöne
Camping Mentalität aber passt nicht für
ein Land was auf auf Wirtschaft
aufgebaut ist und hier vor einigen
Haufen Menschen mit Mitarbeiter
dranhängen wir reden ja hier nicht von
irgendwas
Menschen mit Leben Familie und Patienten
passiert ist extrem gefährlich es ist
ein siede Kessel der da aufbrennt und
ich komme ja nur aus dem Brennpunkt aus
Berlin Köln und ganz ehrlich diese
Silvester die wir da gesehen haben ja
die können ja auch überall passieren und
genau das wollen wir nicht wir genau das
wollen wir nicht und die Polizei sondern
das durchdrücken und wir den Kopf dafür
hinhalten für diese Politik warum und
das war doch sehr schön zu sehen wir
haben und Bürger in Binz in Rügen in
einem sehr hohen Ecke wir haben die denn
reagiert als Habig und Scholz darauf
gekommen sind doch mit entbrüstung und
wennige da und die haben gebucht also
wenn man sich das mal anschaut und ich
alles war noch wenige da muss man sagen
es fehlt also aber die Stimmung ist doch
eher Resignation also man hört von
vielen Leuten die sich Sorgen machen und
die auch wirklich unzufrieden sind und
man hat hier wirklich das Gefühl hier
ist eine Regierung an der Macht die ist
mit sich selbst beschäftigt aber hat
wirklich die Interessen des Landes und
der Bevölkerung irgendwie vollkommen aus
dem Blick verlassen
sie haben heute schon ein paar
historische Vergleiche gemacht also um
die Klüngeleien ging wir haben jetzt ja
am Tisch würde ich sagen alle das Gefühl
dass es schlimm ist dass die Menschen
resignieren dass die Ampel nicht gut ist
war das denn immer anders also ist es
heute besonders schlimm oder würden Sie
sagen die Politik Waschen immer
irgendwie schwierig in Frankreich gibt's
ja praktisch heute keine Gewerkschaften
mehr also Gewerkschaften gibt es nur
noch im öffentlichen Dienst der Rest ist
völlig eigentlich organisationslos und
dann gibt es in Frankreich ein sehr hoch
große Zahl an Krieg her Beschäftigten
und dort gibt es Privileg für die
diejenigen die normalen
Arbeitsverhältnis haben die verteidigen
natürlich ihre Privilegien bei der
französischen Bahn und dann spricht sich
natürlich dieser
Unmut jetzt über diese Rentenreform als
Beispiel
durch das heißt es gibt im Grunde haben
diese Leute die Straße gehen und sich
mit der Polizei prügeln haben überhaupt
gar keine Chance mehr in das normale
politische System eingebunden zu werden
wie funktioniert das bei uns früher das
hätten wir immer soziale Marktwirtschaft
das sind kommen jetzt wieder die bösen
Lobbyisten wir hatten wir haben
Gewerkschaften wir haben
Unternehmensverbände wir haben
handwerksverbände wir haben Industrie
und Handelskammern das deutsche System
ist total verschachtelt und alle diese
Gruppen repräsentieren Teil dieser
Bevölkerung also meinetwegen IG Metall
immer noch eine millionenfacharbeiter
und wenn es jetzt z.B zum Maßnahmen
kommt zur Veränderung kommt dann
organisiert man das gemeinsam es gab zum
Beispiel in den 70er 80er Jahren große
stahlkrisen Ruhrgebiet wir haben die das
gemeldet die haben das gemanagt weil
sich die wesentliche Akteure
zusammengesetzt haben die haben auch die
sozialpolitischen Interessen der
strahlarbeiter vertreten im Bergbau gab
es immer diese schönen Wort keiner wird
ins bergfreie fallen das ist auch
eingehalten worden und wenn man es also
zum Beispiel zu Strukturveränderung gab
zum Beispiel Leute sicher sein ich habe
funktionierendes soziales Netz und alle
Akteure hatten auch das Gefühl die
Politik hört uns zu die eigentliche
Katastrophe die du Habeck hier zu macht
oder dergleichen ist wenn dann die zum
Beispiel das Gewerbe
Heizungsbau und die große Firmen dann in
einem Artikel zum deutlich machen der
interessiert sich eigentlich gar nicht
für unsere Interessen unser Anliegen
egal noch schlimmer weil auch noch mit
dem Klüngel sind nee das Problem ist äh
der hat überhaupt keinen Sinn sorium für
dieses deutsche Verbände System was
dieses Land 70 Jahre lang so stabil
gehalten hat da musst du natürlich auch
die Interessen von einzelnen Akteuren
Rücksicht nehmen das sind nicht einfach
nur böse Unternehmen
genau
Umweltverbände diese ganzen nicht
Regierungsorganisation Fridays for
future und weißt du was und das ist das
eigentliche Problem und wenn das bei uns
zusammen klappt dann fallen wir ins
bergfrei dann kann es wirklich passieren
wie im Kosten oder System nie so richtig
funktionierte dass die Leute dann halt
AFD wählen
völlig apathisch werden und auch auf
andere Ideen kommen aber nicht mehr in
das System integriert sind aber komm
Stichwort Stichwort Wahlen kommen wir
hier nochmal zur königsfrage zum Ende
ihrer These Herr Gräber wird es denn
Neuwahlen geben wie steht es um die
Ampel hält die Ampel der Druck aus also
diese Affäre kreischen was ich so so
höre wobei da auch viel Gerüchte gerade
dabei sind könnte tatsächlich noch
wirklich zu einem Problem werden und
zwar nicht nur für Habicht sondern auch
für die gesamte Finanzierung
gesagt er findet die Vorwürfe
unverhältnismäßig das sieht ja fast nach
zusammenhalten
erstmal ja die große Frage ist Scholz
der ja oft sich nicht so richtig ob er
nicht irgendwann auch mal
in irgendeiner Form eingreifen wird
werden wir sehen das Problem ist alle
drei Parteien haben Angst von Neuwahlen
weil sie nach jetzigen Umfang stand
keine Mehrheit mehr hätten genau das ist
das Problem aber auch und deswegen
befürchte ich fast dass die noch sehr
lange oder noch Halt bis zur nächsten
regulären weil daran festhalten werden
mach mal eine Frage die Runde ja Nein
Spiel wer ist ja natürlich für neue Wein
fangen wir an zu meiner linken Seite ja
Nein Neuwahlen wollen
witzig geben ich weiß gar nicht
okay so drei zu eins ich enthalte mich
damit geben wir in eine ganz kurze
Unterbrechung dann sind wir zurück mit
zwei spannenden Themen unter anderem von
Carsten Stahl
[Musik]
wir haben viel zu besprechen heute Abend
wie steht's denn unser Land
damit herzlich willkommen bei Viertel
nach Hering frei
ist wirklich zu einfach
begonnen aber wir entscheiden doch was
wir machen
eigentlich fordern sie die Aufarbeitung
und den Rücktritt von Karl Lauterbach
lieber umgekehrt das ist nicht
aufgearbeitet und das müssen wir noch
machen als freiheitsliebender Mensch
würde ich sagen das muss jedem erlaubt
sein kein Mensch zwischen Bremer und
Bruder
Winterstart Geld verschenkt muss das ja
irgendwo anders herbekommen das wird das
Problem nicht ändern das ist unser
Mittel war glaube ich auch kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen dass das so durch geht
und das ist leider Gottes auch ein Punkt
mit dem Reden
definitiv noch einmal ein Scheiß
[Musik]
zurück wollen keine Zeit für ihn sie
sehen hier wurde auch gerade schon rege
einfach am Tisch weiter debattiert und
wir gehen zu Carsten Stahl
ja was soll ich sagen für mich ist der
Kinderschutz und verhandelbar und hat
oberste Priorität und ich sehe das mit
Besorgnis wenn ich halt höre dass die
Ampel jetzt ein selbstbestimmungsgesetz
für die Kinder einfügen möchten dass die
Kinder selbst über ihre Geschlecht
entscheiden können
und vor allen Dingen habe ich da mal
eine ganz einfache Frage
da gibt es also Kinder die Kinder töten
der fallouise
13-Jährige bringen gezielt ein Kind um
nachweislich haben sich darüber
informiert wie sie dieses Kind wie sie
jemanden töten können dass er nicht
erwischt werden da wird jetzt nicht über
diskutiert dass Kinder vielleicht dass
man Gesetz anpasst oder wird diskutiert
wird aber nicht gemacht das heißt ein
Kind weiß mit 40 mit 13 12 Monaten und
30 Tagen immer noch nicht das Wort ein
Verbrechen ist okay aber wir wollen
neuen zehnjährigen zugestehen und sagen
ihr könnt schon
entscheidend die Grünen gehen würde
würden wahrscheinlich schon mit drei
Jahren wählen können und da frage ich
mich bietet funktionieren soll und vor
allen Dingen halte ich es für sehr
bedenklich wenn ein
Gesundheitsministerium auch wenn sie
zurückgezogen haben Werbung für
irgendwelche pubertäter macht
wenn jemand sich fühlt in einem falschen
Körper dann kann er bestimmte Dinge
machen wenn er es wirklich für sich auch
versteht und vereinbaren kann und ich
spreche da als jemand der unter der kann
jeder nachlesen ich habe mich um das
gekümmert Jess war ein Junge der ein
Mädchen sein wollte den man aber
anderthalb Jahren versucht hat diese
Mädchen
umzubringen umzubringen NRW tot zu Tode
zu treten auf einen Friedhof ist Mädchen
gekümmert und diese Mädchen wollte ein
Mädchen sein und dafür haben wir uns
eingesetzt das sind sein kann aber auch
ein gewissen Alter
weil man ja das ist auch ein Prozess
aber wenn man jetzt eingreift bei
Kindern so früh und ich hatte letztens
wieder ich kriege ja sehr viele E-Mails
wenn mir jemand also schreibt dass ein
Kind in der Kita gefragt wird bist Du
Junge und ein Mädchen und dieser Junge
macht mit fünf Jahren ich bin ein Junge
und man sagt zu ihm als Pädagogen bist
du dir sicher dass du ein Junge bist
dann finde ich das in äußersten Maßen
bedenklich und ich habe manchmal das
Gefühl das ist das wäre nicht zu diesen
Mainstream steht das wird jetzt gucken
das sind einfach in ist man müsste das
jetzt so sein und von mir ist kann jeder
jeder sein Männlein Weiblein
Waschmaschine Fuchs jeder kann besser
sein was er möchte und einmal ja können
sie denn ihr schlecht auch noch wechseln
wendet alles so sein soll ist es so aber
bei den Kindern gibt es Grenzen und das
ist wieder eine Ideologie die übrigens
aus dem gleichen Haus kommt
die ich sehr bedenklich finde wo liegt
denn für sie die Altersgrenze das für
ein Kind das selbst entscheiden sollte
wenn es wirklich anfängt in die Pubertät
zu kommen und ob bestimmte Dinge zu
verstehen also wenn es 12 13 ist für
mich manche sind ein bisschen früher
helfen halt zwölf irgendwo in diesem
Bereich das merke ich ja an meiner
Tochter ist genau jetzt da ja sie sagen
also jetzt schon dass man mit 12 Jahren
wobei
nehmen kann aber da kann ein Kind
vielleicht wirklich wirklich realisieren
bin ich in einem falschen Körper fühle
ich mich aber werden unter zehn wer
möchte denn unter zehn Dinge anhöre dass
du heute schon dass ich gesagt habe
schon eine Kita auf die Kinder einwirken
teilweise schon dort dran gehen ist es
gibt kein Gesetz nein nein nein nein
nein nein nein das nicht aber ich finde
es halt allein diese Tatsache ist auf
eine Seite zu stellen und darüber zu
reden ihr könnt pubertätsblockering auf
einer Seite eines eines
Familienministerium Gesundheitsminister
ist extrem wenn es doch nicht so wäre
warum haben Sie denn sofort wieder
zurückgezogen wir hören einmal rein wir
haben Tisch sind wir alle nicht
betroffen dementsprechend werden wir
einmal reinhören zu einer betroffenen
wie waren das so für dich als die
irgendwie klar geworden ist ich bin
eigentlich gar kein Mädchen ich bin ein
Junge ich glaub das war auch so
größtenteils im Kindergarten so früh
schon und dann ähm weil ich auch eher so
Lego gespielt habe
oder auch ähm draußen klettern war oder
nicht ist mein Ziel ist es eigentlich
mehr zu werden wie mein Bruder also du
bist ein richtiges Vorbild da hinten
[Gelächter]
ja das ist ein Ausschnitt aus der
Kindersendung Logo die auch für Kinder
ist und da sehen wir ja ein Mädchen das
ein Junge sein wird und auch relativ
jung aussieht ähm Herr Stein genau das
meinen sie wahrscheinlich diese
Entscheidung für sich hat dann kann es
ja diesen Weg weitergehen und wenn es
daran festhält und irgendwann sich
entscheidet auch was zu tun ist es ist
okay aber ich habe immer das Gefühl das
ist der eingesetzt genau das ist so
dahin geübt so hingedrängt wird meine
wenn wir jetzt mal das Beispiel nehmen
also man sieht mich ja heute ich bin
noch ziemlich
Kräfte männliche Persönlichkeit also
auch ich habe übrigens mit Punkten
gespielt als ich fünf sechs Jahre alt
war habe ich gespielt und kannst du so
eine Puppe meine Mutter die ist Inge wie
meine Mutter habe so und was nur weil
ich jetzt mit der Puppe gespielt hat und
was haben sie mit denen gespielt und was
man halt so spielt ja ist schon eine
Weile aber ich sehe immer noch die
Bilder also jetzt nur weil ich das jetzt
habe ist ja jetzt ein elfjähriges
Mädchen das ein Junge sein will und das
ist ja auch schon weiter als mit Puppen
spielen sondern sagt ich will ein Junge
sein ist das jetzt sein möchte und so
für sich entscheiden wirklich
entscheidet aber die Frage ist wann
greift man ein dass irgendwas zu
verändern dass man pubertätsperger
schluckt oder wo man anfängt vielleicht
auch chirurgische Eingriffe zu machen
weil eins darf man nicht vergessen dass
ich ja nicht mehr rückkehrbar ja und das
ist es wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel denke
das Mädchen was da fast tot geprügelt
wurde die ist die wird jetzt 16 das ist
eine ganz andere und die hält daran fest
die bildet auch und macht jetzt
bestimmte Dinge auf einen Grund auf
einen Punkt gebracht ja Geschlechter
ändern ist gut wenn man das möchte aber
nicht zu früh hat nicht zu viel nicht zu
viel weil jeder sollte das sein ja also
da habe ich überhaupt kein Problem mit
aber so ab 12 okay davor nicht
vom Kind zu Kind auch noch Einschätzung
sein aber ich bin jetzt nicht derjenige
der das einschätzt ich finde bloß wenn
man heute schon mitbekommt dass in Kitas
oder in Schulen so drauf eingewirkt wird
ich habe doch gerade dieses Beispiel
genannt und das höre ich nicht zum
ersten Mal dann finde ich es schon ein
bisschen bedenklich wie man da äh schon
so ein sowas aufdrängt als wenn das das
schulschule geht lässt mir geht andere
geht alles schön gut aber zu sagen zum
Kind zu sagen bist du sicher dass du
dass du ein Junge bist und so also schon
diese Verunsicherung reinzubringen halte
ich für falsch und da sehe ich halt
immer sehr viel Ideologie und Wunsch
standen und das finde ich einfach sollte
man zumindestens Bedenken dabei und ich
würde mir das für meine Kinder verbieten
dass man so auf die einwirkt
in der Runde deswegen komme ich jetzt
nach Carsten Stahl jetzt zu ihnen ich
wollte nicht unterbrechen aber ich würde
sehr gerne was dazu äußern und zwar
glaube ich dass es ein bisschen
entspannter von ihrer Seite aus
betrachtet werden sollte weil ich glaube
es geht eher um diese Offenheit dass die
Kinder nicht Angst haben etwas zu äußern
was Sie vielleicht Angst macht weil alle
anderen sie auslachen weil sie keine
richtigen Rollenbilder haben weil sie
niemanden so richtig kennen der das
irgendwie so toleriert oder der
irgendwie ist die die brauchen diese
Offenheit dieses das ist glaube ich eine
andere Perspektive die sie da einnehmen
also ich verstehe es einigermaßen aber
ich denke wir hatten es geht eher dieses
Angst nehmen voll kommt mich voll gemein
zu sagen ich weiß es nicht meine Arbeit
kennen ich gehe an Schulen und hatte
über 100.000 Schüler und mache
Prävention Seminare für Respekt und
Toleranzen gegen Mobbing jeden Tag stehe
ich an Schulen und sage dass man sich
dass sich jeder so sein darf wie er ist
und diese Vorteile nicht da sind das ist
das ist vollkommen Geld absolut nicht
dabei ihn man dass die Kinder auch die
Chance haben nicht zu outen dass sie
anders sind alles okay dass da auch eine
Toleranz und Respekt herrschen muss ich
finde bloß diese diese dieses von oben
schon auf eingewirke und auf Kinder die
noch überhaupt nicht wirklich eine
Meinung haben das zuzuordnen das finde
ich das finde ich bedenklich dass es so
ist wenn ein Kind in der Schule ankommt
ich sage ich möchte lieber ein Mädchen
sein dann unter diesen Weg weitergehen
möchte aber was ist es wenn es heute
Mädchen sein möchte und in zwei Jahren
trainiert werden das ist dieses
induktionierte ansonsten vorbei schaut
euch die Geschichte
die ich Geld geholfen habe aus dem
Rollstuhl die hatten die hat ja die war
Kurzform vom Tod wie wir sie wieder
aufgebaut haben dass sie heute da steht
und sagt ich bin ein Mädchen komm dafür
kämpfen
der These zu dem Fall zurück Frau
wolowitsch kennen sie denn Menschen die
ihr Geschlecht gewechselt haben also die
Menschen die ich kenne wusstens von
vornherein von vorne rein also selbst in
einem Alter von ich glaube das merkst du
einfach ich glaube Menschen die das
nicht verstehen können weil sie
heterosexuell sind weil sie sich ihrem
genetischen Geschlecht zugehörig fühlen
ähm können es gar nicht man das ist so
ein Gefühl entweder fühlst oder du
fühlst es nicht und ich kenne Menschen
die
mit ca 5 Jahren schon irgendwie wussten
aber immer noch so ein bisschen sich zum
Beispiel ich kenne eine Freundin von mir
das kann ich erzählen die kommt aus
Weißrussland
selbstbestimmungsgesetz ist gut genau
und sie hat erst mit
keine Ahnung vielleicht mit 21 oder mit
22 wirklich das ausleben können weil sie
in weißrussell kann sich vorstellen und
dann dem Vater der auch im Militär ist
und so die musste
ins Militär und alles gibt es die musste
alles das machen was sie als Frau
niemals machen ganz ganz schlimme
Beispiel aber es gibt natürlich auch die
Fakten und das zeigen vor allem auch
Studien aus England das auch Menschen
gibt die später die
Geschlechtsumwandlung bereuen und die
später merken sind im falschen Körper
und wir hatten hier auch ein sehr
beeindruckende Frau David blank ähm die
auch das bereut und was man ja auch
nicht verschönern darf denke ich dass es
immer wichtig ist zu sagen
medizinerweise auch darauf hin man nimmt
ja dann sein ganzes Leben lang
Medikamente als er nicht mal eben man
wechselt sein Geschlecht dann ist ja
mein ganzes Leben lang schon auch
gesundheitlich bei einschränkt deswegen
wie sehen sie den Regelungen zu dem
Thema weil ich denke hier ist keiner am
Tisch der sagt man darf es aber nicht
tun oder aber wie würden sie es machen
dass die richtigen Entscheidung
getroffen werden können und zwar dass
man wirklich auch später noch sich gut
fühlt mit der Geschlechtsumwandlung oder
mit den pubertätsblockern
also ich bin der Meinung man sollte
immer noch diese Möglichkeit haben dass
man es selber entscheiden darf also
jeder sollte das Recht haben zu
entscheiden ob er eine Frau Mann nicht
binär oder was auch immer sein möchte
wenn man sich falsch entscheidet
dann ist es halt die Schuld der Person
die sich dafür entscheidet das muss man
sich wirklich gut überlegen es ist schön
das ist also ich finde das Thema
wirklich schwierig
diese pubertätsblocker heißen ja
pubertätsblocker weil sie vor der
Pubertät eingesetzt werden um die Puppe
Tee zu blocken dass ich dann eben als
Frau keine Brüste bekommen und so weiter
aber das heißt doch da muss die
Entscheidung ja in einem in einem Alter
gefällt werden wo man glaube ich so eine
weitreichende Entscheidung auf keinem
Fall dem Kind nur alleine anvertrauen
kann das ist ja das ist das was ich
meine es geht ja darum dass der 21
absolut krass falsch absolut falscher
Weg ja es geht gibt ja die Tendenz dazu
ähm auch in dieser gesetzlichen
Regelungen nicht jetzt so krass aber die
Tendenz dass man eben den Eltern die
eigentlich letztendlich das Sorgerecht
haben die da auch so ein bisschen
entmachten will und mehr dem
kindeswunsch stark gerecht zu werden das
ist kann in manche Fällen sicherlich
notwendig sein und so aber generell
halte ich das auch für gefährlich weil
wir reden doch auch also ich habe da die
altmodische Vorstellung dass mein Körper
halt nun mal so ist wie er ist und wenn
ich gerne Frauenkleider anziehe bin ich
froh dass wir inzwischen eine
Gesellschaft haben wo das möglich ist
ich könnte jetzt hier auch im Kleid bei
ihnen denke ich auftreten hoffe ich ja
absolut aber das nächste mal so ich muss
ja deswegen muss ich doch nicht mich
operieren ist auch kein Problem krasse
Medikamente schlucken und und so das
finde ich nicht die richtige Beratung um
die gute Psychologen das ist rein den
fehlt in der Runde hier ich kenne einen
Fall also das ist ein Junge der hat
offensichtlich auf weiß noch nicht so
genau in welche Richtung sich bewegen
soll und der läuft dann zu Hause halt
oder am Wochenende läuft er halt
lackierten Fingernägel Handtaschen
aber in der Schule geht da ganz normal
er geht in die Schule ganz normal auch
aus dem Grund um einfach
Stresssituationen
ja also das ist und was ich mich an
dieser ganzen Diskussion wirklich ein
bisschen erschreckt also wir haben ja
ein Jugendstrafrecht das
Jugendstrafrecht geht davon aus dass wir
es bei jugendlichen Straftätern erst ab
14 Uhr übrigens ist mir eine Strafe für
mich ähm mit noch nicht voll
entwickelten Persönlichkeiten haben
müssen anders die müssen anders
behandelt werden als Erwachsene weil man
ihn natürlich noch ein gewisses
Entwicklungspotenzial erkennt jetzt ist
natürlich völlig grotesk also im
Jugendstrafrecht gehen wir davon aus das
sind Persönlichkeiten
ausgebildet sind und jetzt auf einmal
zehnjährigen an zu sagen die können aber
so eine Entscheidung treffen es ist für
mich nur ein Wort noch es ist für mich
eine völlig klare Geschichte also jemand
kann erst ab 18 so eine Entscheidung
treffen die kann er dann ja hat auch
Zeit sich zu überlegen und das Problem
ist
Jugendliche oder Kinder sowieso was
lernen die im Kindergarten oder
Grundschule die müssen natürlich einen
Rollenverständnis entwickeln das ist
heute viel komplizierter als zu meiner
Jugend mit sieben acht oder so also das
war einfach die 70er Jahre
da gab es noch festgefügte Rollenmuster
und alles da konntest du mitmachen oder
nicht und wer halt nicht irgendwie sich
zugehörig fühlte hatte schon massives
Problem das gibt's ja heute nicht aber
heute ist es ja viel schwieriger für
Jungs die männlich Identität zu
entwickeln was ist schon eine männliche
Identität heute für Frauen weibliche
Identität was schon alles für
problematisiert und Kinder werden
natürlich mit diesen wahnsinnigen
Medienkonsum den sie haben also ich kann
ja heute wahrscheinlich tausende Videos
zu diesem Thema runterladen die gucken
sich dann alle an wir sind natürlich
nicht aufklärerisch sondern die
verwirren die jetzt noch mehr und man
muss dann einfach die Chance geben sich
zu entwickeln und da ist die Frage
welches gesellschaftliche Leitbild
wollen wir äh wollen wir haben das ist
nicht mehr das Leitbild meiner Eltern
aus den 50er Jahren bei der vor dem
Krieg geboren
sondern heute modernes Leitbild und
dieses modernen Leitbild kann aber nicht
auf klare Planken verzichten und das
bedeutet einfach lebe dich aus Spiel mit
Puppen ich glaube heute wird keiner mehr
im Kindergarten angeguckt vielleicht
aber doch ich nicht so richtig beurteilt
wenn er mit Puppen spielt oder mit dem
Kleid rumläuft aber es machen natürlich
auch ganz wenige Kinder das ganz wenige
Jungs kommen mit dem Kleid im
Kindergarten oder eine Grundschule habe
ich persönlich so noch nicht erlebt wer
das für sie ein Problem nein warum aber
das Problem bekommt er natürlich in
seinem im Umfeld seiner Klasse wir haben
ja heute schon wahnsinnige massive
Probleme überhaupt die Kinder zu
beschulen das Mobbing ja mein Thema fast
schon Alltag 1,5 Millionen Fälle jede
Woche oh oh jetzt ist mein
wie würden Sie Ihr Abschluss Plädoyer
was sie gerne hätten in Deutschland was
wir ändern müssen was wir tun sollten ja
also ich finde es ist ganz wichtig dass
wir über das Thema natürlich sprechen
aber ich finde einfach dass man nicht zu
früh damit anfangen sollte das was wir
da gehört haben dann auch noch weil es
in einem anderen landgeschehen ist wo
sowieso noch andere Werte vermittelt
werden Steine Werte das ist absolut
falsch ich habe zu meinen Kinder ich
habe nur zwei Kinder genau da drin sind
immer gesagt zumindestens absolut so 19
Mann ihr dürft alle sein was ihr möchtet
ich werde mich ich werde immer auf eurer
Seite sehen ihr könnt euch so entwickeln
wie ihr wollt so und wenn sie deine
Entscheidung hätten getroffen dann hätte
ich Sie dabei unterstützt wenn es ihren
Entscheidung ist aber wie oft ist eine
Entscheidung getroffen je nach bei
Kindern ganz besonders nach einer kurzen
Zeit wieder umgeworfen wurde und da
irgendwelche Blogger zu nehmen wo man
noch nicht mal die Risiken wissen was
daraus entsteht finde ich den falschen
Weg und umso früh einzusetzen und da war
er gerade beim gleichen Beispiel wie ich
gesagt habe also für morgen sind sie
nicht zu rechnungsfähig aber dann können
Sie entscheiden da passt was nicht aber
grundsätzlich und das ist mir immer
wichtig wir müssen für eine respektvolle
tolerante und gute Welt entstehen und da
müssen wir jeden akzeptieren wir ist
egal ob mit dem ein oder anderen die
fällt oder nicht aber zu früh anfangen
sollten wir damit nicht vielleicht ein
schönes Schluss plädoy und jetzt kommen
wir zu einem nicht ganz so schönen Thema
was aber immer mehr Deutsche auch
beschäftigt und das ist das Thema
Auswandern aus Deutschland
da kann ich einiges dazu sagen also ich
stehe kurz vor dem Prüfung ich bin im
dritten Lehrjahr als Pflegefachfrau und
ja nach meiner Ausbildung möchte ich auf
gar keinen Fall in Deutschland bleiben
ich sehe es überhaupt nicht ein die
Spritpreise werden teurer die Mieten
steigen
stromgas man kann sich das heutzutage
alles gar nicht mehr leisten ich denke
mir halt so nach meiner Ausbildung was
kommt da alles auf mich zu die ganzen
Fixkosten alles drum und dran ist da
also der fällt einem alles auf die Decke
und dann denkt man eigentlich nur so
wenn man schon so viel schuftet wenn man
schon irgendwie
so viel Geld so viele Ausgaben hat so
dann lieber irgendwo wo man Sonne hat
wenn man irgendwie Strand hat wo man
vielleicht ein bisschen weniger braucht
aber es einem genug wo würden sie
hingehen wollen
also es gibt ja Möglichkeiten wie zum
Beispiel Schweiz Kanada Portugal und
mich spricht Freizeit aber sehr hohe
Lebenskosten da sind sie aber noch in
Deutschland ganz günstig dabei und
Kanada ist auch extrem teuer deshalb
würde ich mich für Portugal entscheiden
ähm
surfe und auch sehr gerne Urlaub mache
und ähm genau mich das auch anspricht
ich habe mich doch schon so ein bisschen
erkundigt da gibt's auch private
Kliniken wo man so wahrscheinlich auch
Deutsche leben wo sie auch deutsche
Rentner kümmern können genau es ist ganz
spannend sie sind wirklich ihr nicht
alleine 2021 sind 329 000 Menschen mehr
zu als abgewandert und es werden schon
auch mehr die auswandern aber wie könnte
Deutschland sehen umstimmen zu bleiben
dann müsste auf jeden Fall was passieren
mit den ganzen steigenden Preisen das
wie soll ich mir das alles leisten wie
sollen sich generell die ganzen Bürger
das irgendwie leisten dann gibt's
Familien die überlegen dreimal ob sie
die Haribos irgendwie dem Kind kaufen
oder nicht oder irgendwas machen wenn
man die Rechnung genau in in ihrem Beruf
auch auf nach der Ausbildung da werden
sie ja dann wahrscheinlich netto wie
verdient man da
weil zwei zwei fünf zwei acht
ach Gott
genau also vielleicht ist es hängt
natürlich vom Arbeitgeber ab von es gibt
viele Arbeitgeber bzw
2000 Euro netto vielleicht zwei netto ja
dann wohnen Sie in der Großstadt oder
auf dem Land ich wohne in der Großstadt
wir sind die Mieten da wie viel werden
sie für Miete zahlen müssen also solche
ehrlich da war letztens eine Freundin
auf einer Wohnungsbesichtigung ich
glaube es war eine Wohnung am
Savignyplatz 13-zimmer 1.000 Euro nette
Gegend aber wissen Sie wie viele Leute
da waren über 100 Leute das tut mir eine
Wohnung genau also das heißt es gibt
genau das heißt entweder gehst du hin
und machst dich zum Affen weil da 100
andere Leute stehen da muss man aber
gleich
sind sie auch 1000 € immer noch auf
jeden Fall arbeitet eigentlich für die
Miete dann möchte man vielleicht auch
noch Vespa fahren oder man möchte
vielleicht Motorrad fahren Auto fahren
oder was man so für für Wünsche hat in
der Freizeit oder so als Verkehrsmittel
wie soll man sich das leisten eigentlich
nur noch für die Lebensunterhalt geht
man schuften man macht sein Leben lang
geht man schuften und nichts dabei hat
und die die sich daran dass es wieder
die Vorbildwirkung die die auch dafür
mit die Verantwortung tragen dass du
isst die euch ja auch viel mehr
versprochen haben und nichts davon
gehalten haben die erheben sich jedes
Jahr die Diäten immer weiter immer
weiter immer wieder 350 mehr immer
wieder
können Sie denn zum Beispiele ja also
ganz ehrlich ich möchte hier auch nicht
mein Leben lang bleiben meine Kinder
sind jetzt 15 und 12 und auch ich sehe
das so weil ich mir einfach vorstelle
wenn das hier in dieser Nummer weiter
läuft ich meine hoffentlich schaffen wir
noch den Turner round aber wenn es so
weiter läuft dann sehe ich das nämlich
genau so dann kann ich geil
eine schöne Klima ja und immer sehen
eins hat man in solchen Ländern du hast
definitiv nicht
immer wieder feststelle das merke ich
auch jetzt mal nach wenn noch mal nach
selbst nach Spanien fliegst du du gehst
jetzt nicht da Einkaufen wurde Tourismus
ist sondern du fährst einmal ein
bisschen raus und so mehr Kato wenn man
sich anguckt was man dafür 100 €, aber
wir haben in Deutschland im Vergleich zu
anderen Ländern die niedrigsten
Lebensmittelpreise natürlich sehr
gestiegen wie jetzt 67% Paprika
innerhalb eines Jahres aber
Lebensmittelpreise da kann ich Ihnen
aber sagen da beneiden uns aber alle
unsere Nachbarn darum als ich es
beispielsweise Niederland studiert habe
sind wir mit den Autos über die Grenze
gefahren und in Deutschland einzukaufen
genau also Lebensmittelpreise fand ich
in Spanien auch immer teurer als
Deutschland
ist das jetzt so wäre wenn man die
anderen Sachen sich anguckt das Sonne es
trotzdem
ein 20 jetzt irgendwo ja das also über
viele viele Dinge und immer wieder das
können wir noch mal zu hat das hat sie
ja Ausgangs gesagt du gehst arbeiten nur
noch für deine Lebenskosten und dann
auch noch schlechte Wetter zu haben mies
gelaunt der Menschen zu haben dann kommt
ja auch noch oben drauf ständig Ärger
mit irgendwelchen Leuten zusammen es ist
zumindestens eine verständliche Sache
die ich sehe und ich bin nur ein
bisschen älter ich sehe natürlich auch
irgendwann dass ich sage jetzt möchte
ich mal ein bisschen Luft schaffen
für Deutschland am Start haben na ich
hör das ich hatte
[Gelächter]
gucken was ist überhaupt die datscheibe
aber
jetzt mal mehr als ich kenne sehr ich
habe ja auch Freunde so aus mit
türkischem Hintergrund und Migranten
Hintergrund und für die ist das
natürlich viel einfacher die können sich
natürlich tatsächlich überlegen gehe ich
mal weniger zurück in die Türkei Türkei
ist ja nun auch Probleme an sich ne
viele Leuten braucht man nicht zu
diskutiert aber ich merke schon wenn ich
mich so umhöre dass viele Leute wirklich
ernsthafter denken und vor allem
hochqualifizierte Leute dass wenn das so
weitergeht hier und dieses Land in der
abwehrspirale Gerät dass sie sich dann
wirklich neu orientieren müssen und man
darf ja eigentlich vergessen die heutige
jüngere Generation die sind alle mehr
sprechen jeder von denen kann eigentlich
Englisch das ist bei mir schon ein
bisschen schlechter und
die sind natürlich insofern auch viel
mobiler als dass die alten Generation
war aber ich könnte mir natürlich wenn
ich mir jetzt überlege also wir bekommen
hier wirklich dauerhaft 10 15% Inflation
die Sektoren in so einem Industrie Gene
Bach runter und steigen weiter an gerade
ist ein kleiner Einbruch hat
das Interview gehabt und wo er gesagt
hat wenn wir diesen Trend nicht brechen
sieht Baden mit teilweise genau und da
sagte Satz also das sieht
Baden-Württemberg aus in den 30er Jahren
wie das Ruhrgebiet heute und das muss
man sich einfach von den Dynamiker
vorstellen und dann kommen sehr viele
Leute dich kenne und das wird auch bei
uns in der Familie natürlich diskutiert
was machen wir dann eigentlich ne was
machen wir denn eigentlich mit unserer
restlichen verbliebenen Zukunft und das
muss die Politik jetzt einfach mal
verstehen also das dass das was wir
jetzt hier haben seit 70 Jahren glauben
die Deutschen ja immer sie haben quasi
Naturrecht auf Wohlstand wir sind die
dritte Größe Industrie Nation der Welt
irgendwie kriegen wir das immer gebucht
und wir sind immer die Weltmeister
werden pandemieweltmeister und ich weiß
nicht was alles für Weltmeister im
Fußball nicht mehr und das ist jetzt
irgendwie vorbei
das Land verliert so richtig
kontinuierlich an Substanz und das ist
die eigentliche Bedrohung und dann
werden die Leute so wie sie dem wird
dann auch Fachkräfte ja und sie sind ja
eine Fachkraft natürlich ist Portugal
ich kenne das in Spanien viele Leute
wohnen bei also jüngere wo bei ihren
Eltern weil die überhaupt keine Chance
haben einen betritt oder Barcelona
Wohnung zu kriegen aber aber die Leute
fragen sich dann natürlich an um zu
orientieren
gerne noch Herrn Gräber fragen wie
sieht's denn dann für Sie aus ab nach
Frankreich ähm Frankreich ist also
wirtschaftlich und politisch ist es
glaube ich auch
das stimmt also wenn ich auswandern
würde die Schweiz käme noch natürlich
die Frage ist auch eines der
beliebtesten ausländere Ziele von
deutschen weil Landessprache man spricht
und natürlich auch weil die
Steuerbelastung dort viel niedriger sind
das ist ja aber auch viel höher das muss
hat einen guten kann man sich das also
gerade im medizinischen Bereich es gibt
wir bilden ja in Deutschland Ärzte aus
die dann in der Schweiz Krankenhäusern
arbeiten
wo kommen unsere Ärztin oder Bulgarien
die auswanderungslust aber bevor wir
jetzt alle völlig deprimiert werden in
den nächsten Tagen in den nächsten Tag
starten würde ich gerne dass jeder von
uns doch noch mal eine positive Sache an
Deutschland sagt sie beginnen
ich muss erstmal überlegen ja ich glaube
ich habe was tatsächlich dass ich
krankenversichert bin also das ist eine
ehrliche das ist was total banal ist
aber man muss sagen in Amerika zum
Beispiel nicht das ist ja alles Themen
richtig die Krankenversicherung
die Reformfähigkeit die Reformfähigkeit
die wir jetzt auch brauchen werden also
zum Beispiel nicht funktionierende
Konzepte einfach sagt die funktionieren
nicht probieren was Neues aus
dass wir sagen können was wir denken das
und dass wir die Möglichkeit haben
umzudenken
schöner Satz und ich würde sagen ich
liebe die deutsche Disziplin und auch
den deutschen Fleiß und morgen abends
will leider nicht für Sie da denn da
bereitet sich ganz Bild groß für das
Jubiläum für die Krönung vor keine
Jubiläum von King Charles sie sehen
Royale Themen sind nicht meine Stärke
das andere Moderatoren am Wochenende für
Sie da bis nächste Woche dann sind
Patricia Platz ist gut
[Musik]